oblivion looks interesting i don't know
for some reason everything looks
technically right there's great effects
unique setup fields character based tom
cruise is always fun to watch morgan
freeman is always great there's twists
there's turns there's mystery there's
sci-fi but for some damn reason i can't
help but feel like i should be more
excited for this movie it's like when i
watch the trailer i am excited for it
but once the trailer is over i don't
care i feel like tom cruise will do a
great job he's already established
himself to be an amazing actor i really
don't care about his personal life i
don't care that he's a scientologist
listen when i watch jerry maguire i
don't sit there and go this movie's
great but i can't enjoy it because he
dated katie holmes
no because at the end of the day he's
good at his job and i go to watch him
work i'm gay for tom cruise plus the guy
looks amazing for 50 years old there's
also action in this trailer but the
action again looks alright and it's
weird the trailer seems to give away
major plot points yet i have no idea
what the [ __ ] this movie's about so i
feel like when i actually watch the film
i'm probably gonna be like well now i
know what's gonna happen because i saw
the trailer tom cruise tends to pick his
movies well so he's really the main
reason why i'm gonna go watch this movie
and plus i'm hoping that he runs in this
film because let's face it no one runs
better than tom cruise just watch any of
his movies he runs on most of them but
anyway this film looks interesting but
it doesn't feel as interesting as it
actually looks so i'm gonna go off a
technicality here and say oblivion could
get it right
all right guys you can tell me your
points below for what you anticipate for
oblivion and if you like what you saw
like the video and if you want to see
more reviews go ahead and subscribe to
my channel
you